aujourd'hui on n'a plus la même offre de
brillance glacée en épicerie ou en
crémerie quelques-unes ont traversé les
époques beaucoup ont essayé de se
tailler une place sur les tablettes mais
ont disparu
par contre d'autres se sont bien
implantés comme les glaces végétalienne
[Musique]
c'est l'été il fait chaud très chaud
pourquoi ne pas se rafraîchir avec une
bonne crème glacée
et pourquoi pas d'une glace végétalienne
les glaces végétalienne sont offertes un
peu partout que ce soit la crémerie du
coin ou encore en épicerie
en compagnie des fripes aux
nutritionnistes ont déballé glacières de
produits végétalien de toutes sortes
c'est un marché en pleine croissance
quand on voit des grandes marques très
établis comme ben jerry's comme häagen
dazs ou même les marques privées c'est
signe que c'est pas juste une tendance
de passage mais qui a clairement un
potentiel de marché est donc clairement
un intérêt des consommateurs des
produits qui suivent la tendance des
laits végétaux et qui une fois gelée se
transforme en dessert glacé la loi
demande d discuté ces produits comme des
desserts glacés et non pas comme une
crème glacée d'abord et avant tout parce
qu'elle ne comptait pas cru
mais en réalité c'est véritablement pour
le dessert
certaines compagnies auront un peu
magique besoin que ces vegan d'ondés
santé ou mais non c'est plutôt parce que
suivi d'une que c'est plus lente et oui
ça le soit un avantage mais c'est a reçu
un des faits a glacé ce qu'on remarque
c'est ce que ça fait à base de boissons
de soya sont souvent plus faibles en
gras mais beaucoup plus riches en sucre
à l'inversé se faire à tire d'ailés
coucou là on est vraiment riche en gras
même en gras saturés duo avec beaucoup
mais souvent un peu plus fervents sucre
donc var est plus ferme en plus tentés
par que ces big n
se fait très peur des kanaks tout comme
une langue une base régulière c'est
préférable mais si c'est très bon au
goût parfois ses desserts glacés ne
contiennent aucune boisson végétale
elles sont uniquement faite à base d'eau
de sucre et d'huile
les glaces crête à partir de boissons de
riz poisson dames ont les agresseurs peu
étrange où
sirop de riz brun
sirop d'agavé marteau des stream de vie
biologique
l'huile de tournesol l'huile de carthame
pour moi s'il y avait besoin de fire ou
bois ton lait de coco en premier show
c'est plus logique
comme les ingrédients qui est que tout
est arrangé nous venons mise
comme dans la crème glacée les quantités
de gras et de sucre sont importantes et
il est facile d'en consommer plus que la
portion de référence
d'une draft est plus jeune que j'ai
besoin que la plupart des gens vont
manger plus succulents d'une tasse ici
on a souvent jugé important de la vie
quotidienne pour le gras saturés pour
une demi-tasse dont si je mettais ont
produit à une tasse des jalouses
j'aurais que j'ai pu serait quoi 140%
justement jean une place des produits
lactés comme ça pour le consommateur
c'est important de toujours vérifier par
rapport à la portion qui lui mangent
donc que c'est la portion de référence
si moi je veux bien mais ce posté il ya
juste un gramme de sucre mais je mange
parfois faire
il est préférable de choisir des
produits le moins transformés oui avait
produit quand même qui fore ressorti
comme étant un des meilleurs choix que
d'autres notamment en raison lors les
ingrédients qui est plus courte qui
retombe peu à quelque chose que je
préfère la maison
un produit de luxe vendus en petit
format mais qui coûte quatre fois plus
cher qu'une crème la cyclassics you
choisi ce type de produit leur que pour
des raisons environnementales
mieux vous repensez à notre affaire
particules le seuil à la noix de coco et
la bande son des cultures intensives qui
affecte significativement
l'environnement si on veut faire une
différence mieux vaut se retourner vers
produits sans ogm idéalement biologique
ou bien vers une crème glacée
traditionnelle fête au québec avec nous
l'impact environnemental ne sera pas
pire que pour les meilleures cultures
qu'on retrouve du côté des états libres
c'est de trouver un produit parfait de
détente ont quant à eux accrus matc pour
le préfet l'idée de choisir un produit
qu'on aime au bout évidemment c'est être
discutée quand même
[Musique]